Jack busovic is apparently on a Ukraine
Hit List You Know Jack conservative
journalist speaker you've seen him and
about he and I have done events together
and been on each other's shows and
anyway Ukraine apparently wants to
Murder Jack that's not good how did I
find this out well uh because there's
this website uh that lists enemies of
Ukraine and it's supposedly an
unofficial website but it looks a little
bit sort of affiliated with the country
uh the the organization that puts out
the list is called Miro tuvores which
ironically translates to Peacemaker they
say it's separate from the government
but I don't really buy it because it was
founded in 2014 by a former Ukraine
government Minister George Tuka it's
it's reported to be run by a former
member of Ukraine State intelligence
under an alias Roman zaitsev and
according to the times of London the
list has been used by government
officials at checkpoints in Ukraine in
addition to official government
databases